[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is up guys welcome welcome welcome
to gamespot stream today we are
streaming uh warner brothers multiversus
it's like a
spin on smash bros i'm david ahmadi i'm
a video producer here at gamespot
and y'all are stuck with me for the next
hour so so let's have some fun
how are we doing today chat i've got
a nice little uh chat stream up so i can
see all you folks on twitch or youtube i
believe so
hassan welcome
let's get
right into it
all right
it should be fun
i managed to have a couple of uh uh
games earlier today it's a i don't know
it's kind of a weird
it's a little
it's i don't know i don't know how to
explain you'll see it it's like a it's
like a weird mix of what you would think
uh smash bros should be
but like
or rather this game tries to be smash
bros but it's like it doesn't quite
replicate it but it's a good time i
think they're pretty creative on uh
how they interpret some of these
characters so we'll we'll hop into a
couple of matches
it's a team based game though
which i think is is interesting and you
guys might notice so a lot of these
characters
have here let's just go into a
free-for-all right off the bat so you
can see what it's like
um
it's a team based game every all these
different characters have like
certain
certain like you know almost like uh
classes like a class system you got
shaggy here he's a bruiser you got a
wonder woman as a tank
oh you got jake as a bruiser as well
raindog
as a support
uh you know you've got assassins you've
got mages you got
freaking
different kinds of um
what you would call it like some
characters are better at being
horizontal fighters others have more
verticality to them
they're all
really
trippy though i have to say i kind of
had some time to mess around with shaggy
wonder woman
uh tom and jerry which is actually
they're really funny uh and so far i
think my favorite has been finn but i've
also been i was kind of like a sword
user in smash bros play a lot with link
and you know characters like that so
uh okay cool so actually unfortunately
it seems like the restream chat feed i
have only shows twitch and not youtube
but i pulled up the youtube stream so i
can see all you guys and the youtube
chat as well so
hello hello to everyone damn we gotta a
very very full chat here this is fun
uh when is it coming out man i actually
don't know but you know what we do have
a preview up um both on this channel
like this very youtube channel right
here and also at our website at
gamespot.com we had uh you know one of
our editors our freelance editors end up
doing a full preview on the game so they
probably have more insight on when the
game comes out than i do um but what i
do know is that this is a closed alpha
so this is not a complete game this is
not a beta or anything like that it is
most definitely kind of like a tech
thing so
i want you all to tell me in the chat
right now who i should play
uh right off the bat keep in mind some
of the cooler guys are locked so
superman batman both locked garnet's
locked steven universe is locked and
arya stark is locked and i actually
liked her i played as her in a practice
lab and she was pretty cool but
so we'll see it
uh
let me know
[Music]
be batman please oh god i wish man i
wish
tom and jerry or jake okay we got a few
tomatoes i got some fans ultra instinct
shaggy now
oh my god
finn finn okay hey looks like looks like
some we got some uh
adventure time uh fans here find the
goat all right
the the chat has spoken
so we're going finn
got my sword got my hat what else do i
need ultra shaggy i'll get out of here
oh my god
it's funny because you guys say that but
he he does have a like a super saiyan
mode he does
he does power up it's it is pretty
pretty spot on
yummy america's confirmed what
they should give bugs
[Laughter]
oh you're so out of pocket i love it
this game is smack bro smash bros rip
off uh you know
prepare yourself i don't
i don't think so i think that
playstation all-stars was a pretty bad
smash bros uh
ripoff you know what i mean
because i remember playing that game for
like
god an hour
and i stopped so i put in the time i'ma
make you mine
oh my god we're getting smacked right
off the bat so the cool thing about this
game is you can dodge
twice and you can like
double jump and move around a little bit
you can also remap some of your controls
so you can um
kind of like
you can make it feel like as if you were
playing on the switch
so that's the
good thing the only problem is that
there's something called um
there's a move decay and you'll see what
that looks like in just a sec you use a
move over and over again
it's like efficacy goes
get down my sword
[Music]
look out i jumped out of the hitbox
placer's all-stars is good get out of
here this is not good
it's a free brawl but i got an assistant
move forward
we have ourselves
[Music]
i'm ready for more bummer
is nanny minnetti
uh no
he's not
yo this map is kind of uninspired yeah
it's like a
pretty neutral map i feel like there's
there's more though it's probably just
like a random you know map that they
played we don't really get to select
uh
which ones there are this is a reskin
brawl holla
all right
i've actually never played brawlhalla so
i don't know if there's things like uh
um
like the power-ups or you know the
different like team-based emphasis that
this game has so
toast 25 gold i could toast someone back
the hell
yeah so there's like missions here too i
mean they've got like this total
life service you know style to this game
where you're just ranking up uh
coins and then y'all you use those coins
to um
to like unlock some of these other
characters and stuff you know
accept a rematch of teams one we want to
toast another player play five matches
okay
seems like
you can do all that oh
yeah so we're playing online we're
playing against other people you can
play against bots
uh there is a ranked mode but it seems
like it's disabled for now you know what
i mean um
and then you've got these different
modes within each of these categories
and they're the same if you do it with
other people online or with bots
so if you go to the bot section
[Music]
i guess they're missing one you don't do
oh no they're all here okay yeah it's
interesting because i really like free
for all
in general when i play smash but this
just isn't a free-for-all
oriented game a lot of your abilities
are meant to be you know to buff and to
support like your teams and stuff but i
was going to keep playing free fall for
a little bit but we'll hop into teams
uh eventually
all right let me do uh let me do fin
again because these matches are super
fast so it's not a big deal
again just so i can get that muscle
memory going and then i want you guys to
drop into chat who else you want to see
i don't mess around with it i can tell
you right now
tom and jerry
is probably the most confusing one
but also the funniest like just the
concept of that character and how they
how they handled it um i was laughing my
ass off in the
in the lab which is their practice uh
arena
man it was so funny i mean like i was
looking at the moves and i was like
there's no way i'm gonna land any of
these but just like their design of it
was was just hilarious
are we all right all right we want to
see we want to see you know uh ultra
instinct shaggy i get it
i'm down with that
oh we did unlock a perk though we got
wildcat brawler which is your team deals
five percent increased damage with melee
attacks on the ground and if it's
stacked it's a 10 damage okay we're just
going to auto equip for now because we
mainly only have those few
dude look at shaggy man shivering
oh that boy's got all the perks unlocked
you see that he's got he's got super
saiyan ultra instinct prepare yourself
you know super saiyan god
uh shaggy ready to go so we might i
might get wrecked
cellar door do i think courage the
cowardly dog will ever be a playable
character
uh
that would be
i feel like they should you know
all right let's see
got tasmanian
devil
the problem is i'm so used to smash
attacks
and this game specifically
penalizes you
if you use
the same attacks too often
i'm just going to ricochet
i'm uh i'm a chicken
y'all see this
i'm literally
literally a chicken
oh that's amazing
yeah so you
i can't let everyone down
seriously
ultra instinct shaggy kind of just
popped off there huh i don't like that
even bad kale gets shaggy that was
groovy ben 10.
the color outline's terrible i don't
know what you mean by that
oh portomager he's got the white flag
man if there's one thing i'm seeing just
from these comments is that
they really got a bunch of characters
that they could uh
that they could really use huh someone
mentioned powerpuff girls like
they got a battle pass too i haven't
checked out the battle pass yet but
all right so we got a little two on fan
got
some of you also tom and jerry someone
said they wanted shaggy
i don't have any power ups on shaggy
though i i ignored him when uh
did i remember to pack sandwiches
of course steve is gonna be your
main all right
if any guys ever played the nickelodeon
one
with like spongebob and
aang from like avatar and stuff so
do i think felix the cat
will ever be a playable
character
he looks the cat
propeller yourself emoji
i don't know
i don't know if they would i feel like
they're going for they would probably go
for characters that have the most um
you know appeal
uh not that felix's cat isn't appealing
but i guess like mainstream appeal right
you want
you want something that like kids will
just be able to recognize i don't know
if a lot of kids are going to recognize
felix this is going to be fun
i can tell
shaggy
this guy
i'm unbreakable
do the weight kicks this is so funny
let's get a sandwich out of here
she caught my sandwich
with your name on it
i know you can catch it i thought it was
just something that only shaggy had but
i guess not
let's get the forward up just need to
get over
oh here god ultra instinct shaggy op
dude he is so funny
oh my god
this is actually ridiculous
i just don't like the uh the distance of
some of these movements so like throws
me off you think you would go further
but you don't no no no that's not how
this is gonna go
oh let's go dude
let's go
in the final second
i'm like splurging for supreme dog he
used the sausages as a nunchuck oh my
god
holy crap that is so funny man
oh you got some people hyped for this
game we got some people to think it's a
it's a mid game or mid versus all right
all right we got some jokes i like it
oh man
got some calls to nerf shaggy that was
that was funny man he really did go
straight koken super saiyan
ultra instinct
any version of uh of shaggy you want and
i guess he's got it they really should
have made his hair turn white i would
have
i would have died laughing dude
dude shaggy oh what is this he's got a
skin
uncle shag
dude all right i'm gonna be honest man i
i like
how
um
almost like
i don't know it's just they
the devs for this game really did kind
of
take some they didn't take liberties but
they're they like
kind of looking inwardly you know what i
mean like laughing at their own
uh
just heightening all the laughs from
each character i think it's i think it's
great man like i said wait till i get to
tom and jerry that i think they're the
funniest character that we have
playstation all-stars is gonna have a
comeback oh okay yeah right for sure
man i don't know what it was about
playstation all-stars dude it just like
it didn't do it for me at all
i don't know i'm probably biased though
i started with what smash bros on the
n64 it was actually the first game
uh literally the first game i'd ever
played was my first console it's an n64
and smash was my first game i wasn't
really good at it i was like four years
old you know what i mean but
but it meant a lot to me actually
growing up
oh did i not add uh power ups damn i
messed up
i know someone didn't say tony soprano
what the hell
oh my god
just putting out hits on uh
on all these characters
prepare yourselves
if you guys could have
let's put it like this if you guys can
have your dream character
from the warner brothers you know from
their ips or from cartoon network your
dream absolute dream character who would
it be
i'm gonna have to use two percent of my
powers this time
two percent of his powers damn shaggy
you really are op
i'm on fire
not like in a good way that was ignited
damn harley
leave me alone
guys
oh my gosh shaggy's op
what the hell dude
yeah baby you can not
that down attack is like this
oh
oh
oh he reversed my controls that was
nuts
i guess i'm not like totally invincible
i'm on fire again
not in a good way
again
i keep thinking it's b but it's x
sorry
look
[Music]
hope you like it
one more
one more opie hit oh
what
you guys seeing this what the [ __ ] is
that
oh my goodness dude that is
so broken
that is so broken are you kidding me
that's like cheap i wasn't even doing
anything man i just like
went off on the little corner of the map
powered up and they just hit the dash uh
oh my god
that is ridiculous
that is
absolutely ridiculous
holy crap
i'm so glad you guys are seeing this
that is ridiculous
got some folks who well yeah let me look
at the chat and see what characters you
guys wanted you got some good you got
some great suggestions
so i wanted neo and agent smith from the
matrix that that'd be that'd be
ridiculous that'd be sick
got some one in harry potter ready
player one terminator
grin yeah grim reaper billion mandy
group adventures
uh
well someone's calling me it's probably
robocult
assuming die hard is winning brothers
you know what they already did um what
game put uh bruce willison already
i want to say it was call of duty but i
can't be sure i felt like it was like a
seasonal pass or maybe they did uh rambo
i think it was like rambo and terminator
but i want to say bruce willis like die
hard was in there so um
yeah we got a lot of power puff uh girls
fans
which makes sense you know blossom
bubbles would be would be pretty badass
uh
samurai jack i think uh is a is a pretty
underrated pick
that'll be pretty good
um
we've got godzilla
secret mountain for teen titans
yeah pretty good yeah these are great
suggestions man y'all y'all be uh
i got some cartoon network fans dede
would be funny someone said dexter and
dd would be pretty funny
so she had like a like a sledgehammer so
like break breakdexter's lab like all
the time
oh man
all right what do you guys think
let's uh let's switch it up although
shaggy is clearly just
clearly the best
uh let's do
let's do wonder woman he's a bit of a
tank he's more of a horizontal
uh character oh
i don't think you've ever met a woman
like me
thinking of mortal kombat john rambo and
t800 are playable characters mortal
kombat oh that's true they are but i
swear uh call of duty did like some kind
of an event with like skins
uh not like characters but just skins
and they were doing something there's
been a lot of anime crossovers too in
these games you got like attack on titan
uh fortnight's been thrown in like
naruto and uh you know you got naruto
skins and sasuke skins things like that
got a lot it's a good it's a good time
to be
uh to be a fan of things you know what i
mean there's a lot of good fandoms
around
that these games are uh putting in
prepare yours oh black screen though
okay
um
that is
that's interesting
let me uh
note yourself watch out i'll just reset
this real quick
although i'm in a game so i'm getting my
ass kicked right now but
let's get my aver back i never give up
thanks for calling out the uh black
screen i'll be fixing real soon hope you
guys enjoyed the volume in the
background of me just
getting absolutely worked
all right let me just do a quick reset
shut down my uh
my xbox and we'll just hop right back in
it might be the game itself you know
probably just crashed and uh
lost the feed
yeah you can see my mouse with that said
yeah don't worry i'm getting the uh
i'm getting it uh uh all fixed up and
trying to just make sure that
this xbox is
giving uh feedback to the aver
uh
let's see
oh
it was there just a second ago oh there
we go
let me see if it nope
i literally had it right the first time
there we go
all right we are back folks and just we
uh
we start this game
thank you for calling that out that's
really very helpful otherwise i would
have just been blabbing
about naruto and uh
sasuke and fortnight
just confirm if you guys can uh could
see the game real quick because i can
see it now and uh it seems like it's
fine but
you know it helps to uh
to know so all you guys on twitch and
youtube thanks again
i do appreciate it
i wonder if it's gonna put me back on uh
it wouldn't
it'd be cool if it could just like put
you right back into the game but i guess
that'd be unfair if someone just bails
you know all right let's do one more
free-for-all with uh wonder woman this
time and then maybe we could try some
teams yeah
see how that uh
how that plays out
i will fight for those who cannot fight
for themselves
we have a visual hell yeah
that's what i like to hear
hey what else have you guys been uh been
playing lately
any good games it could be something new
it could be something old
i for example i so i used to play
if any of you guys follow me either on
twitter or on gamespot if you see any of
the videos that i make i always always
always love talking about or trying to
slip as much destiny 2 as i can in all
of my videos a huge destiny 2 fan
although i've been taking a break until
the new season next week
and so in the meanwhile i've been
playing a lot of uh games on my xbox
been replaying uh dark souls trying to
trying to catch up to eldon ring you
know
and i've been playing a lot of like
overwatch ever since i've watched two's
tech test came out and then a bunch of
shooters so like call of duty even a
little bit of battlefield uh at 2042
despite the meme of it but
you know mr quartz uh you i'm glad you
can see it now but you really hope it
wasn't the game been looking forward to
the game you don't want it to be buggy
you know hey it could have been my obs
um you know we we don't know so
at least we were able to quickly fix it
but
but to be honest i think it might have
been the game which is which is fine
like i said it's a closed alpha you know
hopefully whenever the game gets an
actual uh oh people were waiting for me
my bad um hopefully when it gets a full
release it won't be you know buggy i'm
assuming that's why they released the
closed alpha so
they can iron these kinks out you know
prepare
you know it's fine
got some fortnite talk man i used to
cover four nine for game spot
you know when i got hired i was a uh i
was a game play producer not a video
producer and i was just doing fortnite
challenges every thursday it's good
times
good and bad times but
good times too
all right let's get to it
let's do it oh
i see what happened now
the game just
came black screened again
nothing will stop me this time
that's ridiculous all right
looks like we're just gonna have to
reset again
jesus
yeah i think that is the game because
once we load it in it just it just cuts
straight to black
but then it makes me wonder why
it was working the first time so
we'll do a quick reset
full screen
and we'll see what happens yeah it's got
to be the game itself so that's the
second time it's happened but it worked
uh it worked okay the first couple of
times so
we'll see what the uh
what the issue is
okay
there we go you got some visuals
there
so we'll get this back and
okay
that was a faster fix
you know what i think it might be it
might be when it happens when i pick
wonder woman you think wonder woman's
cursed
maybe we should just boycott wonder
woman for the rest of the stream i think
that's what we'll do
for those of you that are superstitious
maybe that's the uh
that's the play
choose your character
psych i'm doing wonder woman again i'll
see for work do not mistake a desire to
avoid violence with an inability to deal
with it
[Music]
okay
i'm in the little practice room while uh
matchmaking happens so seems like
you guys can see it seems like
everything's fine
come on we can get back to business
yeah let me know what you all are uh
you're playing we got some kirby's
forgotten land nice
someone wants me to check bugs bunny
skin let's do that after no problem
playing with fire oh seems like it
worked this time how do i toast back i
want to toast someone
[Music]
oh there we go
i just toasted them back
i think i got coins for that so
so good news for those of you who were
uh trying to figure out who's the game
i'm pretty sure it was not the game i
think it was actually my avery
as soon as i went into full screen mode
it um it cut to black so
fingers crossed
uh it doesn't happen again
i got a little nervous there i'm not
gonna lie
you want to see shaggy ultra instinct oh
man don't do not worry we've we've had
some uh
some kokin shaggy
on a couple rounds i don't know if when
you guys are saying ultra instinct we're
talking about like a a power up that i
need to unlock we might be able to do it
by the end of the stream we're powering
up pretty fast looks like we're doing
good on time
let's see what's going on
forward
i see my target
oh
charging
[Music]
which i mean my skull
yikes is velma fighting with words
[Music]
there's only one scan per character
available i think each character has
i've seen at least one alternate skin i
don't know if they if there's more
right off the bat or if they're just
going to work on it until uh launch
we will see
um look at no bugs i have a skin i know
shaggy had a skin
i don't know if wonder woman had uh one
but we'll see
got some gold currency
oh yeah okay so yeah there's the battle
pass actually we can check that out and
see um
what rewards your character are on that
battle pass
where's it at there we go battle pass
so it looks like you got a free tier and
you got a premium tier it seems like the
skins are tied to the premium tier you
got uncle shag worthy
uh
oh you got you got uh vfx for ring outs
it's pretty funny
emotes
got taunts
and it seems like the free one's mostly
currencies so you get badges you get
gold you get toasts
what the hell is that what is toast
uh
okay yeah badges and stuff
those uh those bfxs look pretty cool
though
yeah with mega beam i've seen that
before in a round so that's probably
where it came from
got cool banners profile icons
see what else they got
shaggy taunt yeah kung fu let's go can
you see what it can you like preview it
oh no i guess not
bugs bunny taunts
there's got to be another skin here
somewhere right oh here we go got bugs
is uh
bougie skin
someone wanted a a big chunk of skin
yeah right
we got bougie
uh what else we got
tom and jerry variant oh they're pirates
so that's fun that's pretty fun
uh
jake taunt
you know
you taught the nunchucks
okay task force we got task force x for
harlequin harlem queen
uh it seems like
oh yeah jake's got cake
uh yeah seems like that's the the battle
pass so there's 50 tiers i thought there
was gonna be a hundred but that's fine
it's not a bad battle pass i wonder how
much it costs
oh yo i got some gold maybe we can buy
oh two thousand damn okay almost
almost
we should be able to um
oops glad you're back we need to train
that reward we might be able to unlock
batman uh before the stream's over for
sure
play five matches oh yeah that's 500
right there let's go we just need one
more match and then we can unlock either
batman or superman
choose your character all right i'm
gonna go
[Music]
see if anyone had a
request
i could go
kind of want to try wonder woman again i
also kind of want to go back to um
i don't want to do tom and jerry
i'll show i'll show you guys tom jerry
in the in the lab
i'll actually go shaggy why not
dude i hope i don't see it i'll use the
crutch the the kao kim crotch
so one thing that always throws me off
so i'm playing on xbox by the way guys
so when i say x and b and a and y it's
not like on a nintendo controller or
anything like that
so what i'm you know the x placement on
the xbox is kind of like
b on a
on like a gamecube you know what i mean
so that's how i like framed it and they
like swap the buttons a little bit so
there's like your smash attacks
which is a which is fine
you know
but your special
it like i don't know i keep expecting to
press like the actual be on the xbox
controller and it just doesn't
doesn't feel the same
but i swapped the jump the jump
originally set to your a button or your
x button if you're on you know
playstation or whatever
and i swapped it to the top button so
why or triangle just because like
i don't know that's kind of what i'm
used to i guess
are there any series i'm unfamiliar with
and do i have planned on checking them
out what do you mean by series
like game series
i'm fairly familiar on like a
surface level with a lot of things
but actually being good at them you know
narrows down the
category
yeah i don't like this uh level though
just like the lab level it's very boring
dude
finn leave me alone
let me go
okay okay
oh my god dude
i'm getting cooked
leave me alone
[Music]
dude finish chasing me down oh my god
this game has ultimates i don't know man
it might be it might be the power-ups
like if you unlock them you'll
eventually get an ultimate but i can't
tell
that was pretty good fire step it up
damn that was a really bad match
how do users gain access to the
multiverse's clothes alpha i'm gonna be
real with y'all your guess is as good as
mine
i was literally just kind of approached
i was like hey uh do you ever play
smashable yeah i do and they're like all
right you want to code for multi-verses
i was like yeah let's go
so
the day in the life yeah
shaggy's having a bad day oh he was
he needed some scooby snacks for sure
uh but that's okay y'all want to know
why because
uh looks like we got a challenge
completed and
about to get a crap ton of gold
which now means
we can uh
we can pick y'all get to pick who do i
unlock is it going to be
batman or is it going to be
superman
y'all decide
now this menu is not intuitive i will
say that
choose your character
superman looks like it's a tank and a
hybrid character and then batman's a
bruiser and a vertical character
[Music]
i should do just any mini money mo huh
y'all are so predictable i swear i knew
i knew it was gonna be batman i knew it
was gonna be batman superman doesn't get
enough love man
yeah it's it's batman huh it's
definitely batman
yeah it's batman all right
oh
i'm about to be broke y'all i hope you
uh i hope you picked the right uh
the right choice
so otherwise i'll never forget this
we are going batman oh and he's got a
samurai scan i think someone on twitch
mentioned that earlier i missed it on
the battle pass he's got a samurai damn
that is sick
that looks sick man
they'll never anyone see that anime the
batman anime where it's like in japan is
with the joker
it's actually looked tight but i've
never seen it
let's go into the lab let's see what
batman's like
okay
did you just call shaggy a hippie
do you think i'll shaggy
that is funny if you did
choose your character
oh dang people are saying the anime was
bad yikes
oh it's not an anime okay
i thought it was
yo we got a velma main here man level 12
already
the game just come out like
on the closed alpha like a day ago
fun fact if i'm not wrong every time tom
screamed in the classic tom and jerry
shorts was voiced by william hannah
i don't know who that is that's an
interesting fact if true prepare
yourselves
1v1 right now on multiverses i could do
a 1v1 yeah
of course i'm prepared i'm batman
of course i'm prepared
can't use a bomb yet
[Music]
[Applause]
no smoke right now
so fun
what's up facts
fun fact if you um
only go after jerry it doesn't actually
do anything you have to hit tom only
it's like ice climbers you know only one
of the
ice climbers actually is actually
getting over here
out of battle right
dude that noise
damage got a big-ass rock
can't tell that's a glitch or the item
supposed
[Music]
folks
game is terrible looking with the
numbers below each character you know i
kind of like the uh yeah i kind of like
smashes of uh which characters have like
the stock
levels and the percentage at the bottom
just i don't know it's a little easier
to keep track i guess but
you know it's already
they gotta differentiate themselves
somehow right so
lock knee reward what'd i get
utility perk aerial acrobat very nice
okay
all right all right all right choose
your character
let's go batman again he was fun
it's not who we are underneath i keep
saying i'm gonna do the team battles and
i keep going back in the free for all
that's not bad
got a little uppercut
what does that smoke do
anything
choose your character i will say the one
thing that actually is confusing to me
is so certain characters have abilities
that recharge
you know like like the batarang like the
smoke bomb things like that and
their cooldowns each have a symbol
indicating what is trying to be
recharged right and
i mean it's just something that
you'll learn with with time i guess but
right now it's very very hard to know
like okay
you know which one's my batarang which
one's this like remote
smoker name vice versa
dj plays on twitch says uh misses chance
for a key oh well you know
when some you lose
that someone the question
damn shaggy interrupted my batarang is
this can i hear this
deploying smoke
yeah kick in the head
that man's recovery is kind of
ridiculous
maybe the smoke is some kind of like
deep up for them you know what i mean
otherwise
it doesn't really do much
it's like they know where you are you
know what i mean
this one's for shaggy
this one's from shaggy
i wish i made my skull
[Music]
smoke means they can't see themselves
i don't think about that
that's a great uh that's a great point
i just got the win win
i just got the win win
all right let's do a team battle for
real we'll see what that's like
i'm gonna be i'm gonna be straight y'all
i am having fun
i i mean there's something
there's something about it like it's you
know would i rather be playing smash
bros of course
who wouldn't
but
this is uh
this is nice i don't know
i think the more characters that they
get
the better fleshed out this is gonna be
and if they have a battle pass that
means they've got to have seasons you
know what i mean so maybe they do themed
seasons where they bring in like two to
four characters or something
uh and build a roster up you know what i
mean team up with superman oh that'd be
tight if i could i don't know if anyone
unlocked superman though but that'd be
sick
uh let's see
do i
okay here we go
uh normal we'll take this off we'll go
so there's co-op versus ai play casually
gets boss with a friend there's
teamspeak characters that synergize and
use co-op abilities to best your
opponents and then 1v1
uh let's do
[Music]
i feel like i do 1v1
my uh button smashing's gonna get called
out
choose your character uh can i see what
my homies gonna pick or do i just do i
have to pick first
freezer hybrid tank horizontal and
batman yeah we'll do
so
randox supposed to be super like really
good support
um
but i like i know i barely play i wonder
what other one who else is support oh
steven universe who's locked right now
uh
[Music]
oh and velma okay who i can't play with
she is support
let's go batman again
so keep saying go to settings is there a
reason for that
you want me to go to settings
oh
hey okay there's your um
your legacy settings
okay that's cool
i just realized though with the way that
my my uh camera's set up though it's
gonna block the hut so i'm gonna keep it
like recommended like this for now but
that's good to know so if for those of
you who want that um
the smash bros uh
vibe there you go you can mess around
with
oh okay you have the scoreboard you have
it on both interesting
let's do scoreboard
cooldown position we'll do scoreboard as
well
uh
my color my favorite color is turquoise
this light blue
i kind of like this aqua do that
player 3 can be yellow
show my outline
cursor speed okay yeah cool
it's a good set of uh
a set of settings there
all right
back to business
let's see if uh hopefully i get paired
up with superman huh i'm glad i brought
the utility belt
glad about the utility belt
the batman
[Music]
put on mature language in settings
is that an option i don't even notice
what they say
as good as the new characters are same
characters from classic cartoon network
shows would be awesome hope we end up
seeing even more mr quartz from the
youtube chat uh yeah dude straight up i
mean you know a bunch of you guys
earlier man you guys were bringing up
really really good characters of who you
wanted to see i see iron giant's been a
been a recurring favorite though
but how'd they do that man maybe
dj place is noticing a bunch of uh
opie characters we're going up against
yeah man
we're late to the party
oh my god
so we got two attack characters
oh
that was messed up that was nasty
you may even be stronger than the joker
these guys are ridiculous okay i'm
feeling all like inspired and stuff now
game
on point red team
i fought worse
[Music]
yikes
that was wild man
tom was tom was out for blood dude
[Music]
[Applause]
little text lines if you insist
oh who's your character
okay now i can see what he's got all
right you pick first dog who you want to
be
you're a bruiser in that case i will be
a tank
i will fight for those who cannot fight
for themselves
can i hit my partner in teams
uh
well we can find out
[Music]
since rule i take it from your comment
you're new uh to the stream another
smash brothers rip off off
you know i wouldn't i wouldn't call it
that but um
it's been fun we've been having a good
time glad you could join us
and see what uh
what it's like this is like a team-based
smash battle we were doing a lot of
free-for-alls earlier trying to show off
some of the different characters and
their abilities uh there's some some fun
moments but
i feel like the game's uh potential
really unlocks when um
when you start coordinating on these on
these team modes
did fortnite add adventure time poor
knight adds a lot of stuff man
we're talking about like their skins and
stuff it's they're all over the place i
think robocop
robocop is the the most recent one
now smash bros format should become a
norm for things like cartoon network hey
i agree man even that you know the
nickelodeon all-stars thing i thought
that idea was great
um i guess it's not a really popular
it's not a really popular game but
i think the idea is fine to be honest
i won't be pulling any punches
you're right
dude
this cookie coming up
need to remember that move for the
future
watch
there's a lot of missing
stronger than ever
speak truth
the fuse is
hope that shield ain't for sure
[Music]
uh
oh
if one of us dies it just ends it for
both of us damn that sucks
that was a
closer uh
close match
what's that contour you say
happy to oblige
[Music]
yeah the game was close
so folks are asking how do you get this
so i think uh
scroll up real quick yeah so uh the way
that you get this game for those of you
that were curious although it's i think
it might be a little late is you had to
have signed up and then you would have
gotten invited into the closed alpha
they would have given you a key however
there is a beta uh there's a beta coming
up in july uh we believe that you could
probably sign up for that one too i
don't know if it's gonna be a uh
open beta but you know
word 789 is just insisting on the mature
language setting i don't even know if it
exists maybe i missed it what does that
even do that's a
actual thing
unless if you met in stream which if
it's in stream then no we can't really
change that but
i don't think there is a uh
oh that what
ask your parents before turning on
yeah what
what does that do do they just start
dropping
it's like what the hell
all right um
is harlequin assassin okay then i will
i mean you know i think wonder woman was
doing fine uh in the tank that round we
had it so
my mother told me that fighting does not
this is gonna be a hero this is gonna be
uh
on steam or something
maybe i don't know if it's epic or steam
but i know it it is coming to pc that's
for sure
i think actually i feel like i was
offered a pc code
yeah some folks signed up and still
didn't get it
we're at 789 now we can hear shaggy
swear yeah thanks bro it's close
i'm checking the twist chat yeah kevin
yeah it's first the four ring outs and
it's like shared across your uh
your different teams
yeah it looks like we got confirmation
that it is on the uh the steam store
although it looks like we got a black
screen again
i think it is the game
i think it is the game it's got to be
the game this time
because the music's still going and
everything
oh yeah definitely the game
definitely the game
maybe we just wait
wait like 10 seconds
but
if you ask me i think it's i think it
crashed
jg's like oh dear
manny says it's on all systems except
switch that's ironic isn't it
i mean well actually that makes sense
because how the hell are you going to
compare
or compete
on you know nintendo's platform with
smash bros right
does an open beta come out uh we don't
know if it's going to be an open beta
but we do think there will be a beta in
like june so in about a month plus or so
is just this alpha available on pc or
game in general because you have xbox um
it's it's available on a couple of
platforms so i am playing
on xbox uh right now
but it is a closed alpha
give me that gold
give me that gold
team battles is kind of fun though that
was nice do some more uh
let's do some more of that
um oh it seems like you could do like a
little rotation like a playlist
so we'll do that we'll do 1v1 in teams
either i embarrass myself
in a 1v1 or uh
you know
any mini money mo cash tiger by the toe
jk it's batman
i am vengeance i am the knight
oh i got a support uh person the rain
dog
oh we're going against superman oh it's
on
it's on
this is for pride
this is uh you know we got beef going
now
if i uh if i lose to superman
and i will
um
i don't know delete my account
no i'm not going to do that
but this is personal
so i need give me all your energy
and i'm gonna uh
drop some hands on superman
did alfred let you in we're in the
batcave too you're in my house boy
let's go
just get smashed right off the bat
cover activated
stop beating up my rain dog
that's not ready
i could throw my rain dog when he's in
the ball point that's pretty cute
oh
superman
i'll give you that one bruce
buy the seven
and fight well
going dark
can't use a bomb yet
maybe i should have brought my group
tonight
you should have brought my kryptonite
after
all today
let's go
kind of kick superman's ass huh
oh good boy it was a good fight superman
good friend you should give it a rest
again
yeah rematch let's go
let's go
[Music]
choose your character
and it's gotta be batman again
if he swabs off superman
then he's scared
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah same team same teams let's go
[Music]
prepare yourselves
i don't care who i'm fighting
just point me at the target
got my target
walked right into my smoke trap superman
think fast
i don't know why i jumped off the edge i
thought my reindeer would uh
bring me back
[Applause]
not bad batman
coming at you
batman coming through
do you bet he can't like i don't think
he could throw in this game
unfortunately
no smoke right now
out of bath bombs
sorry pal
yeah that was a
nice combo smile
i'll just throw you the wrong way sorry
bro
watch yourself
[Music]
i've still got work to do
coming through
like the wind
oh you have a nice little counter there
huh
nice okay
raindog coming in clutch dude
it's monday what a name i'm sure you'll
get the next one
[Music]
gee geez
good stuff can i give him toast
give him all toasts if i can
yeah
give me that level up bro
gravity manipulation utility prayer
currency gold 100 all right
all right all right all right
let's make a good team yeah man he was
he was
putting in work he was saving my ass
appreciate that
uh
let's do
batman's been that one's been cool i do
want to level up some of these other
characters let's try tom and jerry
i'm not going to go with tom and jerry
it's kind of weird but you know
jace has no actual mature language so
far yeah it's like
oh no way we got the same teams
i love that
um yeah i think it's just shaggy is what
uh what words
789 said
it's just shaggy that uh that i guess
cusses
like beer on twitter so they give a
reason for superman not just one punch
killing everything
shoot
video game logic right
same reason i guess an actual like
movies that he doesn't just
annihilate the earth it's like
self-control right he could kill anyone
at any time but he doesn't because he's
a good guy
because he doesn't know why raindog
jumps off the cliff because he's funny
it's funny
yeah so even though it's the same team
looks like the other team had some perks
so we'll see what happens
oh
i thought it was on the left side of the
screen
all right tom meet tom
you could slingshot jerry which is the
funniest thing i think
stand back
here comes the boom
good
watch your head
hold still
match point red team
[Applause]
the gloves are off now
watch out
i've got this
sorry about this
oh that's it that's a game
take a swing at the shield
see what happens
[Music]
superman have solar flare is one of his
moves i do not just doing my job no or
thinks so i've seen frost
he's like ice breath and stuff no i'm
not actually yeah but i'm gonna change
characters okay
choose your character
all right let's see
oh wait isn't superman a tank yeah yes
okay
although i thought it would be funnier
to have them
you know wonder woman and superman
together
like they're more compatible or
something
[Music]
shaggy superman tom and jerry and jake
from state farm
prepare yourselves
i will say man these load times are nice
it's not too long to get into a match
you know what i mean
i'll show you my new powers
[Music]
to top screaming
i know you guys pointed out earlier but
it just stood out to me that time and
that's so funny
oh you might be a-okay
oh tom's afk dude
that's a wrap
watch this
oh those scooby snacks
oh that's so unfair
oh he's back
watch it
art style is pretty awesome in this
everyone looks cool i i have to agree i
don't know i kind of like it
play again
let's go
i'm patting my stats there
like russell westbrook
or westjet choose your character
quick man let's do it
like man
um
[Music]
prepare yourselves
do they swear yet i don't know man but
shaggy did say do a kickflip which isn't
swearing but it is different
than uh what i've heard what i've heard
from the last like
contained
so you say superman
and i got frying pans in the face
slice and dice
did you hear that
looks like he's boxing
he's breathing like he's taking some uh
one twos
i'm taking these scuba snacks
i'm making that mistake again
i'm taking your scooby snacks kingdom
do a kick flip oh that wasn't shaggy
that's a dewy kick flip okay
[Music]
that was jake that's so funny
time to get crazy
mystery stop
that hurt
oh it's bad team
got me good
going up oh no
[Music]
blue team
fire
oh no
dude jerry just coming out from like a
mile no a single bound defeat
oh no
i choked that one up
and not everyone can do it to it like
yours truly don't feel bad
auto party forming
it just puts me in a group with him
that's cool
i like that
got some new rewards
[Music]
kryptonian skin and make it rain dawg
nice nice nice
y'all remember cartoon network adventure
time
pretty much i actually never saw a
cartoon network's version of it i saw it
on youtube adventure time used to be on
youtube y'all
choose your character it's pretty good
uh okay
so shaggy's fun wonder woman's fun
batman's fun
tom and jerry is funny
but not fun to play
uh finn i played in the beginning and i
kind of sucked ass so maybe it's
redemption time or uh
anything that's evil that's my deal
[Music]
going against captain tank top and beefy
cheesy
i love these gamertags
for those of you who play uh
those who play smash bros
how many of you guys are still playing
uh smash bros ultimate because i fell
off
it was like i was playing it all the
time with my friends but i think once
the panda happened i like just stopped
playing cause i wasn't playing locally
you know what i mean
team mode of gaming how do i have it
early i got a code
through work
uh other folks that are playing online
they got it by signing up and getting a
closed beta in
a closed alpha invite
no one can resist the lasso of truth
going
you cannot escape
no one can resist the lasso of truth
the problem is that the attack decay
it's a good mechanic i think because you
know you don't spam stuff but
it also makes me
unsure
what other moves are good and although
that was tight
it was a good combo
superman
remember me
superman was trying to do a pickup line
on one of them just now i think it's
like remembering me everyone's like
wow that was pretty good because i
better step it up no one can resist the
lack of truth
[Music]
i like these games are pretty uh
even matched though
like they feel fair you know what i mean
they're nice and lengthy
although again i don't like the reach on
some of these on some of these moves
there's like not not enough reach
there's like a weird sluggishness
some of the movements but
i'll probably you know probably get over
it with time
well i will say this i'm doing
putting up a better performance with
finn
this time
and i did the
first match so
there we go gg victory
fighting in the batcave yes i am roozy
oh my god look at this wonder woman my
jumper of the lasso truth it's pretty
good
okay
oh
choose your character seems like four
characters is the max
let's go
well then i guess it's up to me
anyone know if there's items in the game
to use there are um but they're kind of
weird
to be completely honest like i don't
know how to explain it like when you
think of smash
uh the items there's like you know
you've got
home run baths you've got bo bombs
you've got
um healing items you got pokeballs you
got all sorts of stuff
in this one the items that i've noticed
there's some healing items that'll
appear that you can take and will reduce
your percentage rate um of like you know
getting knocked around there are some
items that you can just like throw at
people
and then there's an item that has like a
question mark on it and usually there's
too much action for me to pay attention
but from what i can remember
you'd grab it and it would turn into
like a random item
but if we see any on the ground i'll uh
batman coming through
can't use a bomb yet
now it's my turn
stand back
that bomb's not ready
behind
me let's go
boston you okay
like blew up a bomber as it knocked her
out
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
damn that was a good recovery
resurrection
watch out
i like having wonder woman on my team
man her ability of giving me that gold
shield or whatever is so sick
by the light of
behind me
[Music]
there we go gg
and i'm loving all these comments man
you guys are really interested in uh
seeing the possibilities of this game
and i agree reading all the stuff that
i'm seeing on on the youtube chat here
man like they could go a lot of
different directions
it seems like it could be a lot of fun
back to twitch see dj places plays nick
all-star brawl with a friend
and smash's ultimate is what killed it
for you okay
i remember when uh the ultimate was the
only reason i played um brawl and that
came out it was like you know the
novelty of it but
melee is obviously kind of like the
golden
golden era of smash
uh yeah cool
so
choose your character
seems like
glad you guys been having a lot of fun
i've definitely been having a lot of fun
but it seems like we're kind of reaching
the end of the stream i was checking
with my boss seeing if i could play just
a little bit more for you guys so we'll
do let's do one let's do one good one
you know well we end on a dub right even
though we just won that time but we'll
end on a dub and i promise i won't die
on purpose to extend the time here so i
want i want chad to tell me who you guys
want to see
me play as
uh and i will pick that character
and then you know we'll play that game
out the best of three or whatever and i
might swap if you know we lose one of
the rounds or something and go back to
like batman or shaggy
um
yeah
hit me chat let me know who you want to
see for the last hurrah
we got shaggy wonder woman jake raindog
batman bugs harley quinn
uh i can't play as arya unfortunately
tom and jerry velma finn and taz
cybernetic cataclysm yes there are
different outfits for characters um
each character
i don't know of each but most characters
have at least like one special skin and
you can get it on the uh the battle pass
that's what this uh what's with this
game
dj wants tazz i haven't played his taz
yet so that could be fun
uh
youtube chat's popping off though we got
shaggy
got one for velma
and one for bugs
i got a couple for bucks
i will say this if it seems like there's
you know like a tiebreaker i'll probably
go with the character that i haven't
played with yet just so you guys can see
what that's like you know
so bugs and harley are two good choices
i'm seeing velma as well
i know there's a slight delay with with
my uh my stream in chat so
looks like we got a bunch of uh
vote for bugs huh
scholars myth is the game private or is
it downloadable um it is downloadable
but it is also private technically so
it's a closed alpha uh you had to have
signed up and you would have gotten a uh
like an invite you know if you signed up
for it but a lot of folks in chat they
mentioned that they uh put out
uh their info to try to sign up and get
a code but they didn't so it really is
seems like it's kind of selective
uh
all right looks like we're going bugs
apologies to dj wanted taz and the rest
of guys who
wanted velma or harley
looks like we got operation rabbit
all right okay
bugs with no perks
see how it goes
[Music]
who are we waiting on oh we're waiting
on the
the rain dog
[Music]
prepare yourselves
[Music]
did i see if arya can use different
masks and faces yet oh so yes actually i
used uh arya and the
these are you in like the lab practice
mode and yeah she had this thing she had
the different faces
but it doesn't actually like
i don't know i didn't actually get to
use the abilities as much but i did know
that when i used uh
like when i took someone's face or
whatever it kind of staggered them a
little bit it was the main thing so
holy crap
what's getting worked
ah
damn it
this is a weird map man
i'm fine happens all the time
look you'll get a kick out of this one
and that's it
match point red team
all right
oh
really died that oh yeah no coming back
from that bugs is rough man
bugs is
rough oh you like that it's tough
now we gotta get serious mode on this
rematch
thank you from the brink please
let's go
let's go
oh you can see the platforms looks like
we got xbox it looks like pc pc and i
don't know what that other one was might
have been playstation
yeah
actually hold on you're tom and jerry so
you're a mage then i will be
i'll be a tank
i will fight for those who cannot fight
for themselves
does it have an official release date it
does not
um but there should be another beta
coming around in july so
need earlier is this the
smash killer
probably not
seller actually uh in the chat brought
up a really really good point
which was that
it seems like this game doesn't really
want to compete with smash or be with
smash it seems like it's just tapping
into a market that's clearly saturated
with smash is the the big dog and
they're trying different ideas which is
cool you know
can i can't fault them for that and i'm
going to be honest man i this has been
fun
i mean we've been we've been streaming
since one and it's almost three you know
time flies so
[Music]
definitely been been having a good time
for this one
i really wanted it to have like couch go
up though
that's i feel like that's when the most
fun
i think it does but
i don't know what my last stand is
[Music]
oh there we go
that's what it was okay
behind me
[Applause]
[Music]
i refuse to surrender
[Music]
i will inspire you
yikes that's tough we got rolled
you got a question two guys on the same
team use the same character
man great great question i actually
don't know but i haven't i haven't seen
it happen yet but it seems like uh boy
boy answered in the chat that yes you
can so
but i can't confirm it because i haven't
seen it
mr intelligent says it's going to come
down to people's preference choice
either this or smash or both really uh
and before what you're seeing seems like
the game definitely has some serious
potential
to be huge
i
i agree
yeah choose your character definitely
agree
the rain dog was a monster he was wasn't
there
yeah absolutely was dude i hope i don't
see a ghost
oh dude
raindog is a little low p as a support
character i haven't seen um
i mean i don't think anyone unlocked
steven universe yet i don't think we
played against them oh he's got the cool
shaggy
oh no way
we can't have that
we gotta have og shaggy beat the cool
shaggy uncle shagworthy
how much float do i feel on the fighter
um
it's a good question you know it they
don't really feel floaty they feel kind
of kind of heavy um in a way there's
also like your ability to recover is
pretty
solid if you can get to a wall
you can just jump up the wall like you
can like wall climb basically um
and some characters don't really have a
good like i'm gonna say up b but on this
controller it's up x
uh but they don't really have a good uh
like puppy recovery you know what i mean
so
why does shaggy have powers in this why
not man
why
not
oh it seems like they're shaggy's uh
maggie afk oh no he's back okay
might have been some black
i love how bugs can get pissed
apparently
these guys don't compute
oh
dodge
bugs
fences
[Music]
get ready for a speeding ticket
[Music]
all right
you can dodge in this game the dodging
scheme is really good but it's easy to
forget that you have it i hate families
i barely dodged
yet i've had the opportunity plenty of
times to do it you're about to get
thrown into the sun for that
op shaggy
oh good smash
i guess it's time to increase my power
levels
you just
[Music]
yeah armored butt
[Music]
because
[Music]
thug's gunning for me dude
he knows
off and died damn
i wish i had fairies in it
okay
sorry nephew but that's the way it
crumbles play again
let's go again from the brink
choose your character
go superman bro go superman
a rain dog
receiving universe
if you're gonna be
well it's my turn to be uncle shag
worthy
fisticuffs you say this is the cause
i've got some time i do declare
i feel like i'm out of six flags looking
at bugs and taz
prepare yourselves fancy shaggy and
harlequins probably
a match made in heaven
dude look at velma dancing in the
loading screen that's the funniest thing
ever
this game is so quirky
he's throwing everyone
get that tornado out of here
wow
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what it was it was it was
shaggy couldn't go ultra instinct
that's why
all right we got to do it again there is
no way i'm leaving on on getting bodied
like that
is it free um kind of feels like it
could be i'm not gonna lie
uh i'm not i'm not gonna play with this
guy i'm sorry man
okay
choose your character
batman delight i brought the utility
belt
yeah it definitely has that free to play
um vibe to it
for sure
still prepping batarangs
i hope it has some some lifetime to it
there's been some pretty hyped um free
to plays
in recent memory um but they've kind of
died out you know what i mean like the
most recent one off the top my head is
pokemon unite
right like that came out i played i
played the crap out of that for like a
week
or two
i was hooked you know it's like league
of legends with pokemon and then
just kind of fell off
um fighting a sneeze
oh
that's the worst
oh
don't flip there we go we got these cats
in the bag they got these cats in the
bag that's right
that's right
fences way
harlequin took me off the
map one more underestimating dr quinzal
[Music]
this guy served
your buns are getting kicked
[Music]
no way you thought i was done
oh this is red team
i'll take a whack at it
what's up
unreal
unreal
someone said bugs hefner get out of here
it's bougie bugs
[Music]
[ __ ] no actually yeah we'll do it
yeah dude is like no maybe next time
oh my goodness
get me back in there your character
can't
it's not who we are underneath
it's what we do and like that defines us
oh my god
hopefully there'll be more dynamic
fighting stages like acne
prepare there were some
stages we've seen so far have been what
like maybe four
different ones or so
one of them i don't like it's like it's
like a haunted house and i don't know
the layout of that one it's like weird
it's like a hyrule temple in melee but
that one zone near the bottom left just
like walls and see links everywhere
oh yeah i literally said my least
favorite map is the
haunted house one and here we are
so
it's like you're breaking out of the
house i think that's what it is
like you just smash the walls
and then you know
there's like pitfalls and stuff
that's not ready
still priming smoke
one thing i haven't really been good at
but i know it's supposed to be a big
part of this game is like aerial combat
like juggling and doing air combos and
stuff um this isn't the end
because you can double jump
almost at any time and you can like
do two up attack moves
or like two down attacking two dodges
before
the cooldown like kicks in
that arrangement's not ready
still prepping batarangs that arrange
not ready
i have the battering in my hand
what you mean
smoke bomb's not ready
still priming smoke batman nothing is
ready
[Music]
stronger than ever
i'm gone
still grabbing batarangs
ah
just the ants
how do you get the code
you don't
logiaholic sorry
yeah you missed your chance but there
will be an open beta
um
there will be an open beta in july so
but don't know how to get you guys a
code unfortunately
checking back into the twitch chat
chronic trigger how's it going mr games
five greetings from london
hello hello welcome from london
it's probably like midnight there so
hope you're enjoying yourself thanks for
joining the stream although you've
probably reached our our final match
underneath
it's what we do that defines us i hope
you enjoy it it's been a good time
though
koskinen says hopefully this will feel
fine on a fight pad
yeah it should although i don't know um
do people
you know i'm gonna sound pretty ignorant
but i i don't know if people play
uh
smash on a fight pad if that's even
possible
so
like i don't know if this is a type of
fighting game you would want to play on
a fight pad you know what i mean i feel
like a game pad's fine
[Music]
someone salty
i've got a good feeling about this match
though
look at that chicken
still grabbing batarang
on target
that's not ready attack bombs not ready
yet
that's not ready
there we go
that's a nice combo
what do we say to the manifest god
it was just like flailing in the air
still priming
no smoke right now
out of my way
you're hopeless
yeah i think we got this in the back
[Music]
wait
that's not ready
still priming smoke
this is a good old-fashioned ass kicking
man
i fought worse
behind me
monster
[Music]
there we go
cam yeah that was that was uh those dark
sides omega beams it's uh so you can add
like
death effects basically so you can do
like looney tunes stuff you could do
uh dark sides omega beams anytime i got
a kill there was like a samurai banner
that popped down it's pretty sick
looking back at some of these chats yes
superman is in uh the roster i'll show
you guys the roster real quick but
we're probably gonna be wrapping uh
wrapping this up it was a good that was
a good match to end it on you know
but for those of you who uh
you might have joined us you know a
little late on this stream you can take
a quick look at this roster right here
yeah shaggy on raindog you got steven
universe garnet
harley quinn arya
finn tazz
velma
tom and jerry
bugs batman
superman jake and wonder woman so a
small roster for now it's about uh what
is that 16 you know characters
um it's not a samurai banner but okay
yeah yeah
i mean you can add cool uh visual
effects is the
is the important thing here so
you got a little battle pass here yeah
so you can see all the uh little effects
right now
you do it that's all folks
some good stuff yeah there's the omega
beam you guys are talking about it's not
that far in the battle pass only you
know only gotta get to level seven
and then you can uh
you can access that it's a pretty cool
one
sick sick sick
what's this oh that's my career
uh it shows how many have one and
damn we had a little
l streak there you know what i mean
yeah some good dubs too
got a good collection here and
i thought i had enough gold to unlock
another character for a second but it
seems like you need two thousand
something like 800 off
but we've been uh to be honest we've
been ranking up
pretty uh
pretty solidly
i do say so myself
um can i show some velma unfortunately
not because that is all the time that i
have however
uh
you know you can probably see i'm sure
there's there's other folks that are
streaming as well so you could hopefully
see some some velma in action we
definitely went up against velma
a couple of times she's like a mage
supporter she might be a support class
it's pretty cool
see some of the uh a comment real quick
so did i read my other message about 12
and x copy multiverses could do what
third strike and 12 were supposed to do
all those years ago ah that could be
that could be interesting
man i gotta say
this game was
a lot of
fun
you know i don't know the longevity of
it i don't know how long it's gonna you
know stay on the hype train but i had a
blast i mean we were streaming for about
a little over two hours and that time
just you know flew it was a really bad
snap there we go might be a little
better there we go you know the time
just flew so
i really appreciate you guys joining me
once again i am david david ahmadi i'm a
video producer for gamespot please check
out my videos uh as well as those on the
video team you can subscribe to our
channel
uh you can check out some of the stuff
that we've been covering we got a lot of
good stuff cooking uh you know every
week we have some really fun expert
reacts looking at eldon ring looking at
other shooters
uh we got a lot of great content for you
guys
i don't know when the next live stream
will be
um but i will be trying to you know talk
to the team and see if we could
potentially stream a dungeon run of
destiny 2's new season it's going to be
new dungeon
next friday that could be a fun weekend
stream uh for you guys but
i think that's just going to do it for
me so i once again i appreciate all you
guys coming out here chat has been super
super fun super positive
we've been having a great time so